i was scrolling through spring 2021's
upcoming anime and i saw toki revengers
the manga of which i had heard about a
while ago from a friend
who am i kidding man i don't have
friends so i thought that i would read
it now that the show is coming up to see
whether it is really good and whether
it's worth making a video out of and
yeah it is there are some big titles
this season
like my hero of course and nagatoro-san
but tokyo avengers is one that you do
not want to miss out on i started
reading yesterday
and caught up yesterday not only is it
utterly addicting but it's just one of
the best manga i've personally read
dealing with the very complex inner
workings of gangs in japan
and it offers a very mature story
dealing with actually pretty young kids
which you wouldn't think goes really
well with the topic of gangs but it does
they work quite well together
it's quite similar to erased in that it
has time travel elements to it and that
similar premise
and if you know anything about me the
anime culture corner loves some good
time travel
if you're into anime involving gangs or
enjoy seeing
dudes being really badass and beating
each other up to earn respect and rule
tokyo
or if you love emotional moments that
deal with regret and
love and trying to rewrite your mistakes
while becoming a better man
then you will love tokyo revengers and
today i'm going to talk about all of
this and more
why i really do love tokyo revengers and
why i think that it will
hopefully become the dark horse of
spring 2021
like this manga has truly hit me on
levels that i haven't felt in a long
time
also if you're part of the 95 of my
viewers who aren't subs
hit that button and support the channel
let's go
tokyo avengers follows takamichi a 26
year old who's kind of let his life pass
by him
he's at the lowest he's ever been and
actually peaked in middle school which
is a
that's pretty tough and then his
ex-girlfriend from middle school hinata
the
one girl he's ever loved is murdered by
the tokyo manji gang
shortened and commonly called in the
manga tomon which is what i'll call it
from here on out
and in the modern day toman is a group
of criminals who have committed any and
every crime you can think of and cast a
pretty dark shadow over tokyo
but after a turn of events not quite her
good friend truckkun but
tranquin this time took the spotlight
takamichi finds himself transported 12
years in the past
in middle school when he was still
dating hinata and
thus he uses this opportunity to make
things right and try and save her
by infiltrating toman and rewriting
history
but it's not as simple as tearing tomon
apart from the inside out
as takamichi soon realizes that toman is
far from the terrible organization that
they are in the future
in fact the members who run tomon are
honorable and respectable dudes
bringing up the question of what went
wrong
how did tauman end up the way that they
did could these people really be the
ones who killed hinata
and as he infiltrates he has to unravel
this mystery while also dealing with the
treachery and dangers that lie within
the complex gang system
in place in tokyo but the thing is
takamichi isn't this like super brave
dude
at the start at least he's basically
apologized through his whole life
and whimpered away from any real
challenge and so it's a really rough
start for him
like this dude's getting beat up every
single chapter
i mean he still is towards the end or at
least where we're caught up to but
i mean towards the beginning it was just
completely one-sided
and so if you don't like you know weaker
main protagonists who fight their way
mainly through perseverance and sheer
willpower
you might not like tokyo avengers but to
come to takamichi's side here because i
do like him now
he does change a lot throughout the
manga he gets a really hardened resolve
and truly takes this burden and
responsibility to save the future
upon himself in the way you would expect
of a cool gang member of a cool
protagonist
we see these huge fist fights with dudes
getting beat up left and right
and super touching bro moments really
like no other
but at the same time his story is also
pretty tragic
because the thing is takamichi isn't
trapped in the past
he finds out that he can willingly go
between the future in the past which
might initially sound just like a life
hack but it's not that simple
because while it at first seems rather
simple to stop the rise of toman just
tear them apart i guess stop them before
it even starts
takamichi soon realizes that there are
innumerable factors that continue to
lead to the future he doesn't want
and every time he thinks he fixes it he
goes back to the future just to realize
that nothing has changed
and that it might have even gotten worse
and he loses a piece of himself
each time it's very similar to stein's
gate or re-zero if you've watched either
as there's this constant back and forth
as he keeps trying to get a result
but can't reach it while also dealing
with the consequences of changing the
past
it's the butterfly effect what he thinks
might change the fate of toman
might actually have unprecedented
effects elsewhere
and so the future he goes back to are
far beyond what he could even expect
and so unlike say erased a show that has
a very similar concept
this back and forth between the past and
present or future
exists where he unravels clues to the
origins of tauman and tries to fix the
future as a middle schooler
and goes back to the future to see well
whether it's fixed
and if it's not he has to spend time in
the future seeing exactly what went
wrong and he has to fill in all the
holes between the past and future and
it's just really interesting
but it doesn't really focus on that time
aspect if you're worried that it might
get too complicated or it's not really
up your alley
what's most important in tokyo revengers
by far
is the characters
i've already talked about takamichi a
lot but i think similar to why i love
okabe from steins gate so much
is that i love characters who have to go
through this very intense
mental struggle as they fight on their
own and they can't explain why they're
going through it because
no one in that timeline would understand
and just the way that they fight through
and struggle and face regret each time
is so cool to me
also to leave the topic of takamichi we
meet some incredibly awesome side
characters as we see the inner workings
of tomon and the gang members
especially mikey the leader of toman let
me tell you if tokyo revengers gets
popular
as i hope it will mikey is going to be
that boy of 2021.
like how gojo ruled over the past six
months mikey has that potential
like takamichi the main character he's
kind of a wimp
and he can't really fight but of course
he's still great because of his
determination and willingness to change
and interfere with the
pretty rigid and cutthroat gang system
but mikey is like
calm collected and also insanely strong
he's called the invincible mikey he has
this move where his leg swings straight
up and knocks his opponent out which is
just like
ah god and then there's draken
and chifuyu and baji and mitsuya all of
these guys
have some kind of tragic and broken past
that has led them to be delinquent to be
gang members
and it's this pain that brings all of
tomon together that makes them so
admirable and cool
their reliance on each other and
familial bond
not the future tomon of course the
corrupt and really crime-committing one
but the real timon the original
it's something that takamichi learns he
has to preserve
and find a way to maintain this very
honorable group even if they are a bunch
of quote-unquote delinquents
i i love this manga honestly it's up
there now after reading it all yesterday
with vagabond for me
i'm not saying that it's as good as
vagabond please don't comment like
vagabonds way better
but i've enjoyed it that much personally
but
also i have some worries mainly the
animation studio
tokyo avengers is being spearheaded by
lidden films
which doesn't have the best track record
and by that
i mean they don't have a single anime
above an 8 star rating on my anime list
which is kind of scary considering that
you know it's a decent sized studio with
72 anime attributed to their name i'm
not saying any show below an 8 is bad
but
you know it's not a very good sign in
general
so i am very worried that this
adaptation won't get the recognition it
deserves
be it because it's animated poorly or
just because the manga isn't properly
converted or what have you which would
be really tragic
but if any of you are interested in
manga and the anime falls flat
i do highly recommend reading it it's
awesome
i'm crossing my fingers that the
adaptation is good because
it could certainly become one of my
favorite anime as well if it's done
right
what do you guys think have any of you
read tokyo avengers did you like it are
you excited
let me know as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses